I'm slowly getting kicked out of the kitchen.
The kids are cooking more and more lately.
Today they wanted to make pizza.
So they first started by making mozzarella.
They got two gallons of raw milk.
They left the cream on,
so this was a whole milk mozzarella.
They added their citric acid and animal in it.
Then they cut the curds,
and they strain them from the way.
And then they put the way back on the stove,
heated that up,
and they started to stretch the mozzarella.
It turned out to be a beautiful batch of cheese.
It was so smooth and so creamy.
They did do quite the number on the stove,
but it was really good.
And they got to work on their fire.
The boys are very talented firemakers,
way better than I am.
So they made the fire,
and then they started shaping the dough.
So they shape the dough,
got into a pizza shape,
added the, uh,
the red sauce,
and they added their homemade mozzarella,
some nice meat.
Their goal today was trying to figure out how to slide the pizza off
as easily as possible
from the paddle.
Of course, this one didn't work,
so they had to take it back in and add more flour underneath.
But they later Learned that corn mill was the best option,
not flour.
But, yeah,
the pizza turned out so well with the.
The homemade mozzarella.
It was so stretchy.
Today was so delicious.
Everyone loved it.
Then they just made a bunch of different pizzas,
different toppings with basil and tomatoes.
But overall, there's me and flora just watching them do their things.
Overall, the favorite pizza was mozzarella, pepperoni,
jalapenos. And then when the pizza is hot out of the oven,
you drizzle honey on the top.
And this is all the kids favorite pizza at the moment.
Even Mabel and Martha.
Everyone loved.
It's a little bit spicy,
but everyone loves this pizza.